Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
(Musica)
(Silenzio)
Ludovica: Pensate a cosa succederebbe,
se non foste in grado di ascoltare musica.
Sentire le voci dei vostri cari.
Il suono della sveglia la mattina.
Ecco, questo significa non sentire.
Siamo Ludovica e Chiara,
due ragazze sorde dalla nascita,
e oggi siamo qui
per parlare del nostro nemico,
che fin da quando eravamo bambine
ci ha messo di fronte a mille difficoltà.
La sordità, penserete voi.
No, anche se a volte lo abbiamo pensato.
Il nostro più grande nemico è l’ignoranza.
Chiara: Sì,
perché quello che ci ha causato
tante discriminazioni e sofferenza
non è tanto questo affare,
ma i comportamenti delle persone
dovute a pregiudizi, disinformazione,
e a una piccola dose di cattiveria.
Però parliamo di ignoranza tra persone,
perché a volte le persone non sanno
che una persona sorda non ha niente
da invidiare a un udente.
Molti ci hanno chiesto
come abbiamo dato esami,
come ci siamo laureate,
come abbiamo fatto viaggi,
come abbiamo preso la patente,
Be', una persona che porta
occhiali da vista
può prendere tranquillamente la patente:
perché non dovrebbe farlo
una persona sorda?
E prendere l'aereo
è molto, molto più bello
quando non senti il bambino che strilla
per tre ore, forse anche di più.
Quante volte mi è capitato
di discutere, o di litigare,
con mia madre, o con mia sorella:
staccavo l'impianto, e addio!
(Risate)
Ma soprattutto, evitare
le lunghe chiamate dei parenti!
Soprattuto a Natale, o per i compleanni:
Cosa farai da grande?
Hai figli? Quando ti laurei?
Quanti esami ti mancano?
Con l'impianto, ciao ciao!
L: Sicuramente, molti di voi
si staranno persino chiedendo
come faccio a parlare.
Le persone sorde hanno un apparato
fono-articolatorio intatto,
e con le giuste terapie
possono imparare a usare
la propria voce per comunicare.
Per questo motivo, la legge 95 del 2006
stabilisce che il termine
"sordomuto" non va più usato.
Un’altra convinzione sulle persone sorde
è che debbano comunicare
attraverso la lingua dei segni,
in acronimo LIS,
ma noi siamo la prova vivente
che non è vero.
Le persone sorde possono:
comunicare verbalmente;
possono comunicare
con la lingua dei segni;
e chi è bilingue, entrambe.
Ma non solo, anche gli udenti
possono comunicare
con la lingua dei segni,
perché alla fine è una lingua come tutte.
C: Spesso mi capita
che le persone sconosciute
mi guardino come se arrivassi
da un altro pianeta
Come saprete, esistono
tre tipi di disabilità:
c’è quella fisica, quella mentale
e quella sensoriale,
ovvero che coinvolge uno dei cinque sensi,
come la vista o l’udito.
È più facile riconoscere una disabilità
se ci sono ausili come la sedia a rotelle,
L: La sordità invece a volte
è definita una “disabilità fantasma”
proprio perché c’è,
ma non si vede dall’esterno,
e forse per questo si tende
a identificarla come meno grave -
o peggio, a ignorarla del tutto.
Da un lato,
e questo anche grazie
all’insegnamento dei nostri genitori,
questo ci ha aiutate
a non considerarla una malattia.
C: Io, per esempio, non lo so
perché sono nata sorda.
Mia madre non ha avuto la rosolia
durante la gravidanza,
né io ho avuto malattie da bambina.
La mia sordità è un mistero,
uno strano gioco del destino
che però mi ha portata qui,
su questo palco davanti a voi.
Noi siamo in grado di fare qualsiasi cosa,
anche se non ce ne siamo
rese conto subito.
I nostri genitori ci hanno
circondato da un amore
che ha zittito le discriminazioni.
Non ci hanno fatto vivere la sordità
come una malattia,
bensì come una sfida
da raccogliere e da vivere.
Ci siamo laureate in piena autonomia,
abbiamo viaggiato tanto
e siamo andate a vivere da sole, a Milano.
Come abbiamo fatto? Semplice.
Non abbiamo capito subito
il prezzo dell’affitto,
e abbiamo firmato.
(Risate)
L: Quando ci sembrava di vivere
i migliori anni della nostra vita,
è arrivato il CoVid.
La pandemia ha sconvolto
tutte le persone sorde:
perché oltre al lockdown,
e all’isolamento,
[le mascherine ci impedivano
di vedere il labiale.]
Questo periodo per noi è stato molto duro,
perché dovevamo chiedere continuamente
di abbassare la mascherina
per riuscire a comunicare.
Questo periodo per Chiara
è stato uno stimolo ad aprirsi,
a parlare della sordità con autoironia.
Ed è da lì che, poco dopo,
ci siamo conosciute.
Da questo legame così forte
abbiamo deciso di aprire un portale
per la comunicazione e l’informazione
delle persone con disabilità uditive:
TheDeafSoul, nato due anni fa.
Si parla della sordità a 360 gradi,
ma lo facciamo con un linguaggio
positivo, colorato, e che coinvolge tutti,
superando le barriere della disabilità.
Il nostro canale serve
alle persone sorde e alle loro famiglie,
ma anche per aumentare
la consapevolezza nelle persone udenti
ed educarle per rendere il mondo
un po’ più accessibile.
Il calo dell’udito
è un problema che coinvolge
oltre sette milioni di persone in Italia.
Ciò significa che la probabilità
di trovare, davanti a voi
una persona sorda
è alta.
Ed è bene sapere come comportarsi
per offrire il massimo supporto.
C:Da quando siamo uscite “allo scoperto”,
abbiamo provato a sconfiggere l’ignoranza.
Abbiamo visto la sordità
come il nemico da sconfiggere:
e invece, anche grazie a "The Deaf Soul"
l’abbiamo riscoperta, e imparato ad amarla
e a farne un punto di forza.
Questa è stata
la nostra seconda rinascita.
La prima è stata quando abbiamo ricevuto
il nostro “orecchio bionico”.
Quando vogliamo raccontare
la nostra storia,
diciamo sempre che la cosa migliore
è essere spontanei, senza nessun filtro.
E dobbiamo confessarvi una cosa.
Non riusciamo ad essere fiere
di una condizione che porta dei limiti:
invisibili, ma che ci sono.
Però abbiamo tutto il diritto
di essere fiere dei nostri traguardi,
delle nostre esperienze,
della nostra rinascita.
L: Disabile è una parola
che spesso può diventare
uno stereotipo, un pregiudizio.
Disabile è un’etichetta, una definizione
che ci è stata consegnata.
Ma noi non siamo etichette:
siamo persone.
Perché alla fine, siamo tutti umani,
stiamo tutti cercando
un posto nel nostro mondo.
In questa ricerca, abbiamo bisogno
non solo di ascoltare ma di sentire.
Sentire con gli occhi,
sentire con la pelle,
sentire le emozioni,
sentire oltre i limiti e le etichette.
Che cosa succederebbe,
se da stasera non foste più in grado
di ascoltare la musica?
(Insieme) Grazie.
(Applausi)